um okay um next we've got a
a surprise visitor who we're delighted
to have it's my great pleasure to
introduce jenny ley fleury
jenny is chief accessibility officer at
microsoft leading the company's efforts
to drive great products
services and websites that empower
people and organizations to achieve more
our team is at the forefront of creating
positive experiences that apply
technology to make a difference in the
world
and the lives of individuals from how we
hire and support people
with disabilities and employment to
innovative technology that aims to
revolutionize
what's possible for people with
disabilities jenny uh
i'm delighted to hand the microphone
over to you
hi there folks um it's an honor to be
with you this morning for a brief amount
of time and
and always good to hear chelsea as well
i
i i stalk you my dear on um
on social media in fact many further
speakers
um i i'm kind of humbled to be uh
with you guys today um i'll keep my
comments super short um but i do think
that this is
well it's incredibly top of mind right
now and so i'm really excited to see how
this
uh not just the conversation moves
forward but what comes
out of this as we look at cs education
there's
a sort of some really key elements that
i think are incredibly important
uh whether it's our role as a tech
provider um
as a member of the tech industry because
this is never one company it is a
collective
and as the opportunity to innovate and
drive a new bar of not just inclusion
but innovation coming through uh
the pipeline over time i think if
if i kind of pass out the sections that
become really important
um that i think are achievable i love
that you're looking 10 years out and
roy you're throwing out some great um
you tell me what you imagine um i don't
think any of us imagined this year so
maybe let me start there
um because i do think that while we're
all enjoying this gorgeous
pandemic world that we're now living in
i
i do think that it's also shown an
incredible light
on the need for accessibility somebody
asked me earlier to
give a short version of what i think
that is um
and i'm not known for my short versions
even though i do like twitter
um but if i was to give the short
version it would be that accessibility
has never been more important than it is
today
uh and i think i would have said that
maybe a year ago with a different
level of knowledge than i have right now
um the um
and i do think that one of the most
important things as we
um as we really think about that impact
have covered
is that
what it's done has shown a light for the
need
for technology to be that equalizer
and yet we already had a gap to begin
with um and we have a bigger gap
that's come through at the beginning of
the year
belle and i were sitting um and and by
the way there's a confusion on
interpreters we can say
uh we were not seeing one interpreter
which is why bella is also in church so
if we need to stand one down
just let me know in the chat window and
i will make those words happen
um no confusion allowed for awesome
daffo
um but what we were doing at the
beginning of the year
is we were really getting sort of sort
of clear we had a whole marching order
for 2020 then we very vehemently and
clearly understood
that all physical accommodations were
removed
with physical accommodations being
removed that pushed
everyone on to the technology that we
have today
now the good news is that for a lot of
what we have because we've been working
on
on accessibility i've been in this role
five years we've been working on this
since the 90s we had a lot of ducks in a
row
but there is no way uh that we could
have anticipated that demand
on accessibility features teams
captioning which i'm sure some of you
are using
in this broadcast grew 30x
in april versus february this this year
uh which is just mind-blowing immersive
reader which are tools for folks for
dyslexia to read text
improves reading rates for 10 percent uh
that grew 560 percent
i mean just incredible growth in the use
of technology
but it's also caused us a lot of um
well it's garnered a lot of
understanding of the bar of which we
need to get after
bell and i have not really seen each
other since march
uh except on this gorgeous screen and
making sure that the teams now work for
virtual interpreting
uh clearly jumped at the priority list
in a massive way
if i zoom out a little bit why is that
important well i think if i think about
education and i think about the process
i'm sitting in my little cozy office
i got two kids up there taking classes
one in college
and one in middle school um
all of them we all were a disability
rich family as are many
uh we know that the community of people
with disabilities is growing and it's
likely to grow as an outcome to cover
it makes the lens on accessibility far
more
and incredibly important and i think
there are
three ways that i frame it one is
raising the bar
of accessibility of education
i felt it um as parenting and educating
my kids through this time
um i got two autistic kids and really
making sure that they have the access to
what
they need having access as a parent
to all of the materials we like to send
videos without captions
super fun to watch i'm making sure
as a blind parent as many of the folks
on my team
inclusive and accessible content we've
got to make sure that the fundamentals
are systematically in place
which is a burden of responsibility on
every lecturer every educator
and on the technology providers
to make sure that it's easy to do one of
the
usage stats that hasn't shifted as much
as i thought it's accessibility checker
in office
which you can just click accessible
stuff it guides you through the process
it's not growing anywhere near um
at the level of demand that i
anticipated and honestly i think there's
a
whole huge amount to go before
accessibility just becomes
par for the course every video has
a d closed captioning um it's
all of our materials are just accessible
by design
i think the second pillar for me is
really making sure that
um we have accessibility included in
curriculum
um this is something that i see some
moving forward on
but honestly there is a massive cap
before it is
absolutely cemented and clearly
grounded in our curriculum going forward
i think teach access has done some great
work
some of the heroes who i'm seeing in the
chat window who are on this call which
then makes me horribly nervous
i know we're driving a lot of efforts on
this incredibly important
uh work but i think we need to get clear
maybe to channel roy for a minute
getting five
ten years from now i would love to see
every cs degree include accessibility as
a module
it should be something that is taught
and if you get those two components you
end up then with folks being able to
pick whatever degree they want because
they can go and do that
and then you also get accessibility
being taught as a discipline which is
crucial
for the future digital world that we're
living in and the third one is to tackle
systemic gaps um systemic gaps where we
know that kids with disabilities are not
going between car
between high school and college there's
a massive drop-off based on the stats
and also gaps and opportunities and
research which is why i'm so excited
about efforts like the create uw
center i'm just actually chatting online
with jake
um and jen mankoff uh from uw
uh who are the key folks behind that as
well as to see richard ladner and
others from the faculty on there just
one
phenomenal effort that i think is going
to start to bridge the gap
and we also have a scholarship fund that
is funded by employees that goes to
it's actually open i think for
applications uh right now
and for students uh to get additional
funding
to assist going from high school to
college if you have a disability
just three nuggets of joy um that i
think
uh the key in front of mind for me as we
think about um
as we exit this glorious
dumpster fire of a year and enter next
year the priorities that we'll be
picking up as we go
forward but candidly learning from all
of you
um as well on top of that so three
small tiny nuggets of joy that that um
and i wish i could consume
the entirety of the rest of the forum
here please if you've got anything else
that you think me my team um
the collective gorgeousness of of the
humans at microsoft who are so
passionate and dedicated to this
um i'm all ears they're they're daffy is
but i'm all ears
um and uh you'll always find me on
social media and i
know many of you have my email so bring
it on if there's other things that you
think that we should be looking at but
most of all i just wanted to say thank
you for
building this and investing your time
to move things forward so with that roy
let me pass back to you
thank you very much jenny it's always
great to have your perspective
and uh informative to hear about you
know the priorities
and agenda that you're setting for our
company and i'm sure
as we know will hopefully help support
many
other companies and individuals out
there to achieve and do more
um all right well that wraps our morning
portion
uh for our speakers um we're gonna call
a quick little audible here
and offer up uh 10.50 as the time that
we come back since we're a little bit
over
on our original break time for the
morning talks um you should everyone
should have a link for the breakout
group
that they're assigned to please find
that link and click on it at 10 50
and remember this is where the hard work
begins
roll up your sleeves um put on your
thinking caps
and let's come up with some really
really great compelling strategic white
papers
uh as part of these breakout groups all
right i will see you then
and see you again here back tomorrow
morning bye